a major data breach involving one of the
country's biggest blood testing
providers could affect nearly 12 million
people quest Diagnostics says patient
sensitive personal and medical
information is at risk after criminals
hacked a contract company used for Bill
collection see team correspondent and
CBS n anchor vladimir duthiers is here
Vlad what's at stake for patients good
morning again
quest says patients lab test results
were not exposed but other private data
including medical records could be in
the hands of hackers according to an SEC
filing an authorized user gain access to
American medical collection agency data
between August 2018 and March of this
year a MCA works closely with a number
of companies like Quest which operates
labs across the US and provides clinical
testing services to half of the
country's hospitals and physicians quest
says the AMC a breach affects eleven
point nine million patients that means
everything from bank account information
to medical records to social security
numbers may have been compromised quest
a suspended sending bill collection
request to a MCA which has since
contacted law enforcement and hired
third party security experts to
investigate the data breach this is big
so what do you do if you're a patient
led to protect yourself against this
there are a number of things that people
can do if they're affected by a hack
according to Experian one of the three
major credit agencies a good first step
is to place fraud alerts or credit
freezes on your accounts additionally
patients should request copies of their
medical records for anything they
haven't authorized okay it's very scary
plan thank you very much